the gyro can experienced and I think
there's something that happens to
fighters when they lose that belief that
they can be the baddest [ __ ] in
the world and that does happen when some
fighters they get a few losses and then
they they settle into that journeyman's
position and you know that's what
gustafson just said when he retired he
said I don't want to be a journeyman you
know that journeyman position is a weird
position because you know you you want
to get in shape to win to beat this guy
but you kinda know that you'll never be
the man yeah yeah you know like say if
you're a guy who's in that 205 pound
division and you just keep losing and
then he/she John Jones yeah who's the
greatest of all time just [ __ ]
everybody up and you know you can't beat
him so your training even when you're
hitting the bag and running and all that
stuff you know Jon Jones [ __ ] you up
twice and you know he you can't beat him
you know you can't beat him that keeps a
lot of guys from having the same
enthusiasm and passion that they had
when they were 22 and they thought they
could take on the world and they
pictured themselves on the cover of
fighters only magazine the greatest of
all time you know everybody has these
ideas of who they can be but when that
idea has been shattered and now you're
just a really good fighter some fighters
just lose their enthusiasm for the game
and then there's Diego Sanchez it
doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] about any of
that it's just their direct people you
know what he's going backwards in his
classic words but but I think it's cuz
he focuses on himself you know I mean he
don't it diego's out of his mind for
sure for sure but maybe maybe he's into
his mind you know maybe he's just so
like focused on himself and you know
even if you can't you know if you're
looking at John and you like man I ain't
never gonna catch up to that level I'm
just not gonna beat it right then then
yeah that can really like you said like
start to really like discourage you a
lot but then if you're just like okay
I'm better than today than I was
yesterday and you know my jabs like a
little is not as straight as it could be
so let me just work on that and just
pick the next thing and just keep
constantly going to that I feel like
that's what real champions doing are
necessarily look at you know the the
other person and Diego he
even if he ain't got the belt he's still
in his head like that's maybe high
thinking I don't know you had to talk to
him he seemed like a crazy do be crazy
there's all different kinds of crazy
right ya know I mean when when I saw
Diego Maul Mickey gall
I was like yeah damn look at this guy
yeah yeah he just have lost no no
enthusiasm zero zero loss and enthusiasm
after all these years of fighting you
got to realize that guy won The Ultimate
Fighter season one in 2005 we are now
here I was at 9th grade 14 years high
school yet Jesus 2005 is crazy crazy he
beat Kenny Florian in the finals Kenny's
long since retired you think all the
people he beat long since retired
it gives it you gives you hope a little
bit you know I mean like know when
somebody else has done it so it can be
done I think he's just you know into his
own head and just like is constantly
getting better and that's really what
the game is about anyway remember when
he so walked to the Octagon screaming
yes yes yes yes yes I would love it he's
so [ __ ] crazy in the best way yeah
yeah that's way he's out his mom he's
still one of my favorite guys to watch
yeah for sure